ma vie c'est être lié avec toi tout le
reste n'a pas d'importance
tu dis oui je dis oui je comptais mais
jusqu'à mamar moi t'as pas vraiment dos
au mur d'argent n'est pas le cas pour le
club
625 à la louche y en a pour 20 millions
moi je sais pourquoi je suis là et quoi
je lis pas tu veux savoir combien de
vous
roger qu'un diplôme de droit était a
permis de voler mais toi peut pas
vraiment dire que tous les profits tout
petit je suis inquiète
l'amour tout ira bien
si tu continues sur la voie que tu as
pris tu finiras par faire des choix
d'entre morale que tu n'aurais jamais pu
imaginer
réfléchissez bien avant de formuler un
voeu
tu pourrais le regretter
m on a un problème
la cargaison la disparue
j'ai eu un coup de fil de nos associés
ils ont perdu 20 millions il ne creuse
tous impliqués c'est ça non seulement
vous m vous ne crois pas aux
coïncidences
ils en ont entendu parler mais ils n'ont
jamais vu tu as des ennuis
écoute
quand les coûts vont partir
je serais déjà
je fais quoi trop de lui
la discussion
c'est trop tôt
en un clin d'oeil je peut disparaître et
vous
écoute
le message venir
les débats sans doute notre imagination
ou simplement dit que vous avez créés et
comme vous allez cesser d'exister ce
monde que vous avez créé disparaîtra à
son tour
cher